pourquoi choisit-on d'avoir une famille
nombreuse comment vit-on quand on
partage à 10 ou 20 le même toit les
mêmes repas le même amour Chantal et
Thierry donc vous êtes à la tête de ce
que l'on appelle une famille nombreuse
vous avez 43 et 44 ans vous vous êtes
directeur donc d'un cabinet d'expertise
comptable et vous évidemment vous avez
du travail à la maison donc vous êtes
mère au foyer je prends ma petite fiche
pour parler un peu de de tous vos
enfants parce que j'ai sinon je je oublz
donc Jean Renaud vous avez 23 ans vous
êtes en dernière année de d'école
saint-cire Laurence en 4e année de
médecine vous avez 22 ans à côté donc
Caroline 18 ans Claire 16 ans vous êtes
toutes les deux donc au lycée encore
Anne Sophie 12 ans Benoît 8 ans Vincent
6 ans et Clément 5 an et demi 5 ans et
demi excuse-moi je suis désolée et
Clément tu as quel âge 4 ans et tu es le
tout
dernier est-ce que vous quand on on dit
que vous avez une famille nombreuse
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
c'est une famille nombreuse ben oui h
c'est pas très courant supp à partir de
deux ou trois on parle de famille
nombreuses maintenant enfin on les a pas
vu arriver hein on s'en est pas rendu
compte qu'il c'était nombreux on l'a
constaté à la fin c'était un un désir ah
oui un vra désir ah oui c'était une
vocation une vocation oui une vocation
VO le mot tu peut-être un peu fort
disons que quand on s'est connu on s'est
aperçu que chacun de notre côté on
voulait une famille nombreuse alors ça
s'est bien trouvé et puis on voulait six
enfants et puis à partir du 6e on a
trouvé que ça allait bien et que on
avait très envie de s'en offrir de de
plus alors on a continué c'estàd vous en
parlez comme d' cadeau c'est ça ah oui
ça oui chaque fois oui il y a eu des
surprises il y a eu des des volontés il
y a eu un peu tout c'est ça c'est le
nombre nous a permis de
varier vous à l'époque donc vous vous
aviez un travail j'étais étudiante quand
nous sommes mariés on était étudiant
tous les deux d'ailleurs oui et puis on
a pensé qu'il fallait qu'un des deux
quand même fasse bouillir la marmite et
alors j'ai très vite arrêté les études
qui m'ennuyé à mourir et j'ai travaillé
à ce moment-là et puis j'ai arrêté de
travailler donc quand j'ai attendu la
3ème et là je suis rentrée à la maison
au pas de course vraiment pourquoi vous
êtes dit que votre votre place était à
la maison c'est pas une question de
place je pense que d'abord dans notre
vie il y a certains moments où on a
envie d'être à la maison et d'autres
moment on a v envie de plus y être ou de
ne pas y être je pense qu'à ce moment-là
j'avais très envie de rentrer à la
maison et j'ai toujours et vous n'avez
pas eu le le sentiment à un moment donné
de faire un sacrifice pour les enfants
oh non tu as fait des sacrifices non non
non plus non non les sacrifices non ça
dépend ce qu'on appelle des sacrifices
enfin je vois tous les jours des tas de
gens qui font des sacrifices pour leur
carrière pour pour des tas de choses là
non non j'ai pas l'impression que vous
vivez avec avec combien par mois t tous
les 10 donc entre 20 et 23000 francs ou
à peu près oui oui ça vous suffit vous
en sortez ça fa plus que le
CIP c'est-à-dire vous pouvez vous pouvez
partir en vacances
vous tout est calculé calculé non ceux
qui nous connaissent bien vous diront
qu'on a jamais rien calculé que ça
quelque fois ça fait des petits
problèmes mais effectivement non on a
jamais rien calculé alors quand on a de
l'argent on en dépense quand on en a
plus on arrête d'en dépenser mais les
vacances c'est vrai c'est peut-être le
budget qui a été le plus sacrifié je
pense depuis quelques années est-ce qu'à
un moment donné pour des raisons
économiques vous vous êtes dit il serait
sage de de ne plus avoir d'enfants ou en
fin de compte vous la question de des
enfants et la question économique n'ont
jamais interféré sinon on en aurait pas
h oui non ça jamais interféré on a non
mais vous ne vous êtes pas dit c'est une
folie aujourd'hui dans le monde dans
lequel on vit avec le chômage est-ce que
ce sont des choses que vous entendez on
nous le dit on on a pas encore été
persuadé sinon on n serait pas là est-ce
que les enfants cette famille ça a été
un ciment entre vous je pense pas que ça
soit je dirais plutôt que c'est le
résultat du ciment qu'il y a entre nous
plutôt que d'avoir arrêta le ciment
entre nous oui je pense que si on avait
pas pu avoir d'enfants je pense qu'on
serait toujours quand même là tous les
deux pas une course en avant pour pour
nous tenir ensemble pour éviter la
solitude sans avoir peur à un moment
donné que ça fasse éclater la famille
parce que le nombre allit être trop trop
impressionnant ça c'est matériel ça peut
faire éclater la voiture si est trop
petite ou l'appartement mais la famille
non il y a toujours de la place ce qui
est amusant dans dans votre famille si
j'ai bien compris c'est que chaque
enfant en fin de compte et chaque aîné a
pris sous son aile un cadet c'est un peu
l'inverse ce sont les cadets qui ont
pris sous leurs ailes les aînés ah ils
se sont choisis un grand pour l'aider et
quel est le premier qui a commencé c'est
Vincent c'est toi Vincent tu as tu as
choisi qui pour s'occuper de toi
Caroline ah c'est
Caroline Caroline peut-être tu peux un
peu en parler est-ce que dans ces
momentsl tu tu as l'impression toi aussi
d'être c'est quoi c'est tu secondes ta
mère tu es un peu tu te sens aussi un
sentiment à ce momentl mat én aussi
vis-à-vis de de ton frère qui se
développe ou c'est ça reste un sentiment
de sœur non ça reste un sentiment de
sœur sentiment
maternel je laisse pour maman mais nous
c'est un sentiment de sœur ça c'est
c'est assez fort quand même assez grand
sans qu'on ait besoin d'avoir un
sentiment maternel en plus
Laurence alors donc c'est en fait c'est
Benoît qui a choisi Laurence c'est ça
voil moi je pense que ça VI plutôt du
fait que au fur à mesure que les petits
sont nés le plus grand qui était là
c'est un petit peu peut-être occupé du
du bébé qui venait d'arriver et puis
c'est vrai que effectivement après c'est
le le plus petit qui a qui a décidé de
passer peut-être un peu plus de temps ou
de faire des sorties un petit peu
exceptionnel comme le cinéma ou autres
visites avec le le grand choisi Anne
Sophie je pr fille resta plus que moi
les garçons avaient déjà choisi
donc vous c'était une joie d'attendre à
chaque fois avec vos parents un
autre un autre frère ou une autre sœur
forcément chaque fois
ou mais c'était nécessairement une joie
parce que chaque fois qu'on nous
l'annonçait c'était bien arrosé donc ça
ça commençait bien par une bonne fête
quoi c'est vrai qu'à chaque annonce de
de bébé en plusan arrivit avec un petit
cadeau pour chacun des des grands déjà
là et on savait que si on ce jourl c'est
arrivé qu C fois pour lesquel je me
rappelle on avait un petit cadeau et on
comprenait tout de suite que c'était
parce qu'il y en avait un nouveau qui
allait arrivé une grande famille une
famill nombreuses ça vous apporte quoi
la famille est une présence et c'est
l'endroit où justement on peut être où
on peut être aimé sans avoir besoin de
faire quelque chose d'extraordinaire ou
de de montrer quelque chose on a on a
pas besoin de montrer que qu'on est
qu'on est quelqu'un ou qu'on ou qu'on
est capable de faire quelque chose de
bien quand on est dans sa famille c'est
l'endroit où on peut être aimé pour
soi-même Jean Renaud pour vous c'est une
chance d'avoir une grande famille oui
j'en suis parti il y a 5 6 ans j'étais
content d'en partir mais je suis content
d'y revenir régulièrement
Clément dis-moi est-ce que est-ce que
toi tu aurais envie d'avoir encore
d'autres frères et sœurs
oui ouais tu voudrais encore avoir une
plus grande famille
oui et et
pourquoi parce que j'aime bien tuaimes
bien parce que tu t'amuses beaucoup
plus
et toi est-ce que quand tu as su que tu
que tu allais avoir encore un petit
frère est-ce que tu étais content oui
ouis tu joues souvent avec lui
oui avec qui tu joues le plus dans la
famille
avec Benoît Clément Anne Sophie dis donc
ça en fait beaucoup ça et laence est-ce
que toi tu as une préférence au fond de
ton cœur carolineclair ah c'est Caroline
clair les deux les deux filles et et
pourquoi tu es plus souvent avec
elle parce que je les aime ah tu les
aimes et toi
Benoît bon moi je préfère avoir beaucoup
de frères et
sœurs et pourquoi toi aussi parce que
comme ça s'il y en a quelquesuns qui
sont partis bah on en a quand même pour
jouer
est-ce que vous vous avez de
l'admiration pour pour vos parents oui
énormément pour d'abord pour avoir une
famille aussi nombreuse arrive à nous
supporter tous avec nos caractères
et c'est sûr c'est difficile d'avoir h
enfants parce que bon il y a des
caractères différents des réactions
différentes et donc de vivre tous
ensemble
c'est c'est c'est difficile est-ce que
vous ça vous a donné envie plus tard de
de d'avoir une famille nombreuse oui oui
oui oui pour enfin moi pas je veux que
je avoir minimum quatre enfants ah ça y
est c'est décidé dans votre tête c'est
décidé ça dépend pas que de moi oui
Caroline est-ce que vos parents sont
aussi un exemple pour plus tard ah oui
oui je pense que oui parce que on les
voir après 23 ans de mariage et
euh les voir s'aimer toujours autant
enfin moi j'étais pas allé 23 ans mais
enfin j'imagine que c'était avant aussi
et euh disons que ça donne un exemple
c'est ça donne de l'espoir en l'avenir
parce que on on se dit enfin je me dis
que le que si ils ont réussi he pourquoi
je réussirais pas moi et et vous aussi
envie de d'avoir beaucoup d'enfants
parce que ça pourrait être l'effet
contraire hein ce qui arrive dans
beaucoup de familles non non non
ouis donc pour vous ça a été un atout
d'avoir une grande famille c'est
toujours un atout
ou Laurence j'ai pas envie d'enfants
maintenant tout de suite non ça me dit
je je ne me vois pas me mariant dans les
dans les années à venir et dis donc que
c'est pas pour l'instant ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est pas une de fonder
une famille et avoir plusieurs enfants
Renaud si vous me demandez aussi si j'ai
si j'ai envie d'être Perre de famille
pour l'instant je me sens pas assez
stable ni sédentaire pour le faire et
j'ai surtout pas envie de programmer les
choses à
l'avance ça me paraît ça me paraît
possible puisque l'exemple me prouve que
ça peut marcher mais je pour l'instant
je me dessine pas encore vraiment parmi
les aînés est-ce qu'à un moment donné
vous auriez eu envie d'être d'être seul
avec vos parents est-ce que le fait
d'être justement dans une famille
nombreuse temps en temps de l'affection
vous a manqué ou du temps pour vous ou
jamais on a toujours eu droit à un
moment seul avec nos parents à un moment
soit parce que les autres n'étaient pas
là où où il faisait exprès de nous
emmener rien que nous donc on a toujours
eu droit à un moment seul un petit
moment seul et et au moment tous
ensemble donc ils ont bien réparti en
fin de compte ce qui est important
justement dans dans dans le fait que
maman soit restée à la maison c'est que
les petits ont besoin de beaucoup de
temps forcément Clément a besoin de plus
de temps que Caroline nouclair mais ce
qu' ce qui est important c'est que pour
les grands on a peut-être besoin que de
5 minutes par jour
de la présence de maman mais ces 5
minutes là on y avait droit ça j'imagine
que ce n'est pas évident Chantal non ou
ça c'est à faire ou ça seit de façon
instinctive arriv moi je pense parce que
on avait des tas de principes tous les
deux quand on s'est marié on les a
abandonné les uns après les autres mais
j'avais décidé par exemple que que mes
enfants pouvaient venir me voir quand
ils voulaient que donc j'allais
m'installer au salon de telle heure à
telle heure le soir un 5 à 7 quoi si
vous voulez hein le salon de Madame
Fayole avec mont deacomodage à côté moi
j'ai toujours eu horreur de ça et il
serait venu me voir spontanément et puis
je me suis retrouvé seule au salon
pendant une semaine je me suis embêtée à
mourir personne ne venait me voir donc
j'en ai déduit que mon idée était
mauvaise c'était pas à heure fixe qu'ils
avaient besoin de moi faut que ce soit
spontané on a toujours dit que le c'est
pas la question de quantité de temps qui
compte c'est le savoir que au moment où
ils ont besoin il faut qu'on soit là il
y en a un qui peut nous prendre tout le
temps ou presque sans que les autres
soient laisés pour aut temp toute façon
le temps c'est quoi c'est c'est la
représentation de l'amour qu'on a pour
eux moi je dis souvent l'amour c'est
c'est infini alors quand on le divise il
en reste toujours autant ce qui veut
dire que si vous aviez encore des
enfants il y aurait encore autant
d'amour pour tous ceux qui arriveraient
bien sûr ça c'est évident il y a eu un
désir pour vous de d'avoir encore plus
d'enfants est-ce qu'il existe je sais
pas si c'est c'est comme ça que je
dirais je dirais qu'on a eu beaucoup de
mal à se dire qu'on allait arrêter
d'avoir des enfants parce qu'en fait on
les aime à tous les âges à nouveau né
c'est magnifique c'est c'est c'est
splendide d'avoir un bébé les grands
diront pas le contraire parce que dès
qu'il y a un bébé chez des amis se la
capare un petit petit moment donc c'est
magnifique un bébé mais on les aime nous
on les aime à 4 ans à 10 ans à 20 ans et
on les aimera à 70 dans la mesure de nos
moyens à ce moment-là de les voir partir
peu à peu ça a été c'est c'est difficile
c'est difficile parce que c'est mitigé
comme sentiment de les voir partir c'est
mitigé au sens qu'on est content
justement de se dire bon ben on a
peut-être réussi quelque chose
puisqu'ils arrivent à être autonomees
puis c'est quand même un certain
déchirement de voir partir un enfant
donc c'est c'est c'est un sentiment
mélangé comme dit benenin il en reste
toujours à la maison ça c'est vrai ça l'
pas pué de dire quand même quand sa sœur
est partie en première année de médecine
si j'avais su j'en aurais choisi une
autre et puis Anne Sophie qui n'aime pas
la solitude elle vous dis tout à l'heure
que de temps en temps elle est seule je
me souviens un jour avoir téléphoné à la
maison et je lui dis qu'est-ce que tu
fais me dit je suis toute seule avec
Papa Jean-Renaud Laurence Caroline
claire et Benoît donc c'est une
conception de la solitude qui est quand
même très mais quand vous voyez l'avenir
vous disiez vous voyez avec les petits
enfants disons qu'on sera très content
de voir les enfants de nos enfantsou
voilà ce qui est normal voilà c'est ça
donc ça va pas au-delà je pense qu'on
sera très content de d'être tout seul
aussi de temps en temps S comme on le
fait comme on essaie de le faire en tout
en tout cas votre couple n'a pas pâti du
nombre d'enfants nêes pas père enfin
vous êtes père et mère mais vous êtes
aussi mari et femme d'abord mari femme
et après père et mère c'est c'est une
conséquence c'est pas c'est pas le c'est
pas le fond est-ce qu'il vous est arrivé
d'avoir de grands conflits entre vous à
cause des enfants ça oui ça peut arriver
oui à cause des enfants si he oui je
c je me rappelle pas que ce soit
tellement à cause des enfants parce que
comme je suis assez diplomate en général
et voilà disons que il a dû y avoir un
premier jet de ma part qui a été arrangé
par ta
diplomatie donc comme quoi il faut bien
être deux c'est absolument indispensable
pour justement contrebalancer les les
mauvaises humeurs si elles existent ou
les volontés si elles sont trop fortes
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut beaucoup se
parler quand même beaucoup se parler
beaucoup on a pas de mérite alors à
beaucoup parler on est mérit de nous
tous les deux on a un tempérament quand
même très expansif donc pour ce qui est
de la communication en principe il y a
pas eu tellement tellement de problèmes
on aime un petit peu si vous voulez que
ça bouge donc d'une certaine manière les
enfants s'adaptent beaucoup mieux que
nous donc ça passe très bien enfin quand
quand on était quand ils étaient plus
petits Jean Ren appelit notre maison la
tante il disait que c'était son ça pour
lui c'était le nom qu'on devrait donner
à la maison on n'aimerait pas savoir par
exemple que la maisonon est est la
dernière et ça sera toujours la même
avec les objets au même endroit enfin
j'allais dire que si on avait été
ordonné tous les deux on aurait vite mis
là-dessus une une croix définitive donc
vous êtes désordonnés ah oui par nature
par goût par par prédilection par choix
par par c'est la vie dans ce que vous
dites c'est parce que vous aimez la vi
parce que l'ordre d'une certaine manière
l'ordre nous fait peur nous impressionne
si vous voulez et donc on peut vivre
dans le désordre en ayant une grande
famille ce n'est pas l'ordre qui fait
que l' disons que le mot désordre c'est
on le comprend ce qu'on veut dire c'est
dire que il faut de toute façon que
certaines choses se fassent
mais on arrive à les faire avec le
minimum de conflit puisque dire tout le
monde il adhère et il
participe pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne in mire Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche